Ось якою Анґела Меркель 16 років тому заступила
на посаду канцлера Німеччини. За час свого урядування вона мала справу
з чотирма президентами України: Віктором Ющенком,
Віктором Януковичем,
Петром Порошенком
і чинним Володимиром Зеленським.
Протягом перших двох канцлерських термінів  Україна
майже не з'являлася на порядку денному ФРН.
Під час президентства Ющенка та Януковича у німецько-українських відносинах
не було вагомих проривів. До 2014 року Україна
для німецьких політиків та суспільства загалом була просто
однією з пострадянських республік, де панують олігархи
та корумповані політичні еліти. Євромайдан, анексія Криму Росією
та війна на Донбасі кардинально змінили ситуацію.
Якщо до цих подій Меркель була в Україні лише один раз,
то після - вже чотири рази. Україна вийшла зі "сліпої зони" Німеччини,
й Анґела Меркель, на думку оглядачів, стала саме тією політичною фігурою,
яка опинилася у правильному місці в правильний час не лише
для українсько-німецької історії, а й для світової. І ось чому.
Німеччина не підписувала жодних документів, які зобов’язували б
її підтримати територіальну цілісність України чи виступити посередником
між Україною та Росією після агресії Кремля на початку 2014-го.
Цього очікували радше від Сполучених Штатів і Великобританії,
які свого часу підписали Будапештський меморандум і тому мали зайняти
значно активнішу позицію. Але саме Берлін став головним міжнародним гравцем
у конфлікті на Сході Україні. Міжнародні експерти часто називають Німеччину
reluctant leader, тобто "неохочим лідером", для якого реакція на дії Росії
стала вимушеним, а не обов’язковим кроком для захисту не стільки
інтересів України, скільки міжнародного права та безпекового порядку в Європі.
Україна заслужила усю можливу підтримку для успішного економічного
просування і на шляху до миру. І Німеччина продовжить надавати цю підтримку.
Власне, завдяки особисто Меркель вдалося стримати вплив Росії на трьох рівнях.
Перший- у рамках німецької урядової коаліції та серед бізнес-спільноти ФРН,
де є чимало тих, хто ставить під сумнів доцільність санкцій проти Росії.
Другий рівень - вплив на країни Європейського Союзу.
Меркель відіграла ключову роль у запровадженні, продовженні та посиленні
санкцій Євросоюзу проти Росії. Звісно, ці заходи ЄС могли бути ще більш жорсткими,
але без наполегливості канцлерки санкційний режим міг виглядати ще слабшим
або взагалі не бути запровадженим. І третій рівень- вплив безпосередньо
на Росію й особисто на Володимира Путіна,
навіть попри те, що Меркель часто критикували за її розмови з господарем Кремля
з огляду на його агресивну політику щодо України.
Меркель у буквальному сенсі недосипала через Україну.
Особливо під час виснажливих переговорів у Мінську в лютому 2015-го,
які завершилися аж під ранок. Канцлерка вела перемовини впродовж 17 годин.
Завдяки позиції Меркель вдалося зупинити активну фазу бойових дій на Донбасі,
хоча питання остаточного закінчення війни досі залишається відкритим.
Натомість позиція Анґели Меркель у питанні членства України в НАТО
була далеко не такою позитивною для Києва.
У квітні 2008-го на саміті НАТО в Бухаресті Україні та Грузії відмовили
в отриманні Плану дій щодо членства в Альянсі.
Роль канцлерки ФРН у цьому вважається однією з ключових.
За словами учасників тих перемовин, Меркель виступила проти ПДЧ для України.
Нині чимало політиків та експертів вважають, що саме блокування
євроатлантичної інтеграції України та Грузії розв’язало Росії руки для агресії
в Грузії у 2008 році і потім в Україні у 2014-му.
Загалом питання інтеграції в НАТО - один з найбільших подразників
у відносинах між Києвом та Берліном. Переважна більшість німецьких політиків
виступають проти членства України в Альянсі, щоб не псувати відносини з Росією.
Підтримка німецьким урядом проєкту "Північний потік-2" -
нині одна з головних проблем у відносинах Києва і Берліна.
Цей газопровід побудували на дні Балтійського моря і він має транспортувати
російський газ в обхід України до Німеччини, а звідти - далі на європейський ринок.
Україна б'є на сполох через політичні небезпеки, які несе цей проєкт.
Однак Меркель завжди невтомно запевняла, що "Північний потік-2" -
це суто економічний проєкт і його не слід політизувати.
Ми вважаємо, що "Північний потік-2" слід добудувати.
Це проєкт, який втілює російський і європейський бізнес.
Натомість Україна, Польща, країни Балтії та особливо США вважають,
що ЄС через цю трубу стає енергетично залежним від Росії.
Вашингтон навіть запровадив санкції, щоб не допустити добудови
"Північного потоку-2". Але в липні цього року Меркель і Байден
досягли згоди щодо добудови газогону.
6 вересня було зварено останню трубу, і тепер справа за сертифікацією трубопроводу.
Під час свого прощального візиту до Києва у серпні цього року Анґела Меркель
запевнила Володимира Зеленського, що Берлін не дозволить Москві
використовувати газ як зброю і готовий запровадити нові ще жорсткіші санкції,
якщо це станеться. Утім, Київ поки скептичний щодо таких запевнень.
Тим не менше попри це відносини України й Німеччини нині значно кращі,
ніж на початку канцлерства Меркель та взагалі за час двосторонніх відносин.
Українцям є з ким порівнювати: з одного боку, Меркель, яка доклала чимало зусиль
для допомоги Україні у стримуванні агресії Росії, а з іншого - попередник Меркель,
ексканцлер Шредер - друг Путіна і головний міжнародний лобіст інтересів "Газпрому".
Крім того, Німеччина- третій найбільший донор України після ЄС
і Сполучених Штатів Америки. Німці інвестували сотні мільйонів євро
в українські реформи, а також консультували український уряд,
особливо в питаннях реформи децентралізації.
У часи пандемії коронавірусу уряд Меркель підтримав Україну,
надавши безкоштовні вакцини. Але все ще відмовляється надавати зброю
попри наполегливі прохання Києва.
Незважаючи на всі злети і падіння, українці, схоже,
таки сумуватимуть за Меркель. За даними нещодавнього соцопитування,
серед ключових світових лідерів українці найкраще ставляться саме
до канцлерки ФРН: аж 73 відсотки опитаних позитивно оцінюють її як політикиню.